if you suffer from pelvic organ prolapse
or stress incontinence
your doctor may recommend the use of a
pessary
the muscles of the pelvic floor and
other supporting tissues
hold your bladder uterus
and rectum in place if these muscles and
tissues
weaken your organs may shift out of
their correct position
resulting in pelvic organ prolapse
a pessary is a device you can insert
into your vagina
to support and lessen the stress on your
bladder and other pelvic organs
to insert a ring with knob pessary fold
it in half
place a small amount of lubricant on the
end without the knob
use your fingers to spread the labia
carefully insert the pessary into the
vagina
as far as possible use your index finger
to rotate the knobbed end of the pessary
upward
you should not feel it once it is in the
correct position
you may need to try several sizes and
styles to ensure proper fit
because even the best fitting pessary
may cause irritation
your doctor will want to check you every
three to six months
this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description